it was a simple story about a boy who
was lost and a girl who was broken
they fought alongside a survivor a war
veteran and a fallen Knight I led them
into battle against an evil so terrible
it tried to black out the stars we
fought for each other we fought for
those who could not but we never
imagined it would end
like this
[Music]
it is a time of difficulty
sometimes impossible one
as long as we're together we've got a
chance least we'll go down fighting
all paths are coming together now time
to get to work
we are the balance Ezra
we were meant to be Jedi so we could be
here now when lo Thor needs us most
may the force be with you
[Music]
so much star wars happening this weekend
this is the final season of rebel so
also try to explain the next animated
series that they'll be rolling out there
is that forces of destiny animated
series that they tease but that's really
shorts I'll play the trailer for that
later in this video but the really big
announcements first ahsoka is confirmed
is coming back date baloney even wore
this funny t-shirt and of course they're
not going to kill our off-screen
comic-book rules if you don't see their
death on screen they're still alive out
there somewhere
I won't leave you not in time
[Music]
then you will die in obviously Darth
Vader is out there too you have to
remember that this is leading directly
into the events of rogue one which then
leads directly into the events of the
original trilogy so as this is the last
season it'll lead directly into the
events of rogue one Hera will become a
general because she was named drop
during rogue one there was general
syndulla so if you missed it when Yuri
watch rogue one during the Yavin four
sequences they actually call her out on
the PA system as a general so by the end
of season four she's going to be a
general and Warwick Davis is going to be
voicing this character here his name is
rook he's an okra warrior who's one of
the personal bodyguards of throg so it's
just another character that they pulled
from the EU but he's drawn related so
you have to imagine if they're going to
bring Thrawn into the Canon and they're
going to bring all the other really cool
stuff that comes with them in the really
cool thing that the story group did is
that they just canonized Rex as this
person during Return of the Jedi so Rex
has been here for almost every single
Star Wars iteration with the exception
of the new sequel trilogy because if
he's this old at the end of Return of
the Jedi then just think about how
ancient he would be when episode 7 picks
up but you know who knows they could
always stick Rex in the new trilogy
somewhere too but like I said throt is
the big bad the connective tissue with
rogue one in season four is going to
explain why during rogue one the
rebellion is so hesitant to move against
the empire like it takes Jin or so a
long time to get them up to speed they
have to get the plan then they finally
join the fight by the end of the movie
they move a fleet in or a portion of
their fleet they end up losing it but
they get the plan so they get their
fighting chance and you get to your
original trilogy storyline with the
destruction of the first Death Star but
rebels has been all about the creation
of the rebellion itself they went from a
bunch of splinter cells like sauger era
is the leader of one of the splinter
cells this really hardcore he's
confirmed to be coming back during
season 4 the rebellion started out with
separate groups like that then they
slowly came together with the
organizational help of Mon Mothma who's
also coming back during season 4 and by
the time you get to the end of Reve
season four and early rogue one they are
officially the rebellion that you
remember from the original trilogy but
basically what they're saying is is that
Thrawn is going to smash them hardcore
and make them super afraid to do
anything when we get to rogue one
but row 1 and the destruction of the
first Death Star sort of the rally
moment for the rebellion when they start
to go on the offensive so there is a
number of questions that they have to
answer by the end of the series 1 what
happens to all of these characters with
the exception of Hera who we know makes
it to rogue 1 because she's a general
but what happens to Ezra what happens to
Sabine what happens to Zeb what happens
to the rest of the crew the ghost in
chopper were actually there during the
rebel sequences on Yavin 4 and then
later during the big final battle you
can actually see the ghost here in this
big fight here choppers here in this
background scene so they're still alive
but where were they during the original
trilogy there's just so many questions
left to answer sometimes they leave
those for the comics in the books but as
this trailer tells you you know like we
started out as this ragtag group of
broken people that came together we
became much stronger as a family
together that family became the
rebellion so that's why by the end of
the trailer you see Hera in full rebel
gear as all these fighters punch in
ready to get down to business so let me
know what do you guys think a rebel so
far and yet it sucks that it's going off
the air I think it had a pretty good
audience even though it's primarily
aimed at younger viewers there was never
a big audience for it on YouTube like I
know you guys kind of check it out every
once in a while but it's not a
week-to-week thing like a lot of the
other TV shows that I do but if you
haven't been watching it I recommend you
check it out at least for Thrawn just
because they're on is such a huge
character in the Star Wars universe that
hasn't quite made it to the movies yet
maybe someday in one of the anthology
movies but speaking of the movies so
obviously Star Wars is going to do
another animated series set during a
different time with a different group of
characters the thought is is that
they've always been moving towards a
series set during the new trilogy so
that means set during the events of last
Jedi episode 9 episode 7 just any time
in-between there with some of the
characters that you're probably familiar
with some of the resistance characters
so they haven't officially confirmed
what that's going to be it'll probably
be Comic Con before
a hint about that they're still trying
to promote rebels but just expect a
series set during the new films so you
guys can let me know if they do that
what do you want them to include because
typically what they do with the animated
series is that there are a few
off-limits characters we saw baby Luke
Skywalker but like I wouldn't expect
them to do a series about Luke it would
be cool to see what he's doing between
Episode six and Episode seven but
typically the cartoons are for filling
in the gaps with the exception of the
Clone Wars just because that happened
during a time when they weren't making
any new movies George Lucas hadn't
really shown any interest yet in making
a new trilogy what's going to happen
next is is because there's so much Star
Wars stuff that I've been posting next
will be Game of Thrones and Doctor Who
and if there's anything else that's
really big I'll try to post it but I've
been posting so many videos so I'm going
to try and step it back to like two
videos a day which is like my normal
schedule just because it's been so crazy
this weekend so there's anything that I
haven't done a video on you know Star
Wars related that you want me to do just
let me know in the comments I know
there's still a whole bunch of questions
about the last Jedi and what's going on
with the future of the force is Luke
Skywalker completely lost his mind
because he wants to get rid of the Jedi
Order so a lot of that we can address
next week but the video schedule should
relatively return to normal in the next
day or two
but while you wait for that you can
click here to learn about all the Easter
eggs in the last Jedi trailer and you
can click here for the battlefront 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you